the Luxembourg government is creating
legislation and providing 220 million
dollars in incentives for companies to
begin mining asteroids and snot bot is a
drone from DJI that is helping
researchers study whales by safely and
easily collecting their snot Vsauce
Kevin here this is mind blow
gauntlet is a levitation glove personal
interaction group developed the gauntlet
that uses acoustic levitation to allow a
user to handle fragile or dangerous
materials without touching them they've
also developed other acoustic levitation
manipulation tools including the sonic
screwdriver and ultra tongs acoustic
levitation was first mentioned in mind
blow 50 back in September 2012 as a
static system these new tools allow for
basic maneuvers and human controlling of
levitating objects representing a major
leap forward for the technology also it
just looks awesome keeping busy and
Bristol researchers are developing a
shape-changing handheld device Cuba
morph uses turntable hinges on cubes
that can accommodate six touchscreens
each allowing for a variety of
programmable shapes to provide modular
interactivity the successful
proof-of-concept could lead to mobile
phones transforming into game
controllers as the materials and designs
get smaller cheaper and sturdier if
you've ever wanted to hear the Milky Way
then thank and asteroseismology
astrophysicist from the University of
Birmingham measure tiny changes in the
brightness of stars determine their age
and mass they recently detected
oscillations in the oldest known cluster
of stars in our galaxy at 13 billion
years old here's what they sound like
let's rock
it turns out snails use just two brain
cells to make decisions for example one
neuron encodes the presence of food and
another one gauges the snails
motivational state so there's food and
I'm hungry leaves too let's eat the
study can lead to building new
decision-making systems based on only
two neurons
more specifically robot brains EXO skin
is a shape-changing material that
creates tangible interfaces with tactile
feedback developed by the MIT Media Lab
the material consists of silicone
triangles on flexible bladders and allow
it to change texture their first
proposed use for this would be a
steering wheel that integrates GPS
navigation directions naturally so you
can actually feel where you need to go
and ultimately their plan is to break
the divide of human-computer interaction
allowing people to physically interact
with digital systems Solar Impulse 2 is
a single seater zero fuel airplane which
recently landed safely in New York City
after a trip across the Pacific Ocean
and will next cross the Atlantic it uses
SunPower solar cells to collect energy
for charging lithium batteries during
morning flights at altitudes up to
28,000 feet at night it glides to lower
altitudes and uses the battery power
until sunrise
they hope eventually it could someday
provide a clean renewable method of
transportation mind blow 82 in May 2014
featured Wi-Fi clothes along with Wi-Fi
the bebe suit concept featured GPS and
Bluetooth to turn your clothes into an
mp3 player well today there's a company
called machina that's making wearable
technology including a jacket that plays
music in the hood using Bluetooth
connected to your smartphone and a new
virtual reality jacket the out-of-body
experience jacket is embedded with
sensors to allow the movement of your
body to affect VR turning the user into
an immersive controller by wearing a
normal-looking jacket instead of some
weird suit
finally thanks to a new algorithm
humanoid robot Atlas can now detect
partial footholds and autonomously
adjust itself to stay balanced
I'm believing with a brain interface for
controlling robots swarms and as always
thanks for watching
hello hello is it because it
I can't hear much of anything sounds
like someone crying oh but my dear you
mustn't be so critical of course it
sounds strange at first these British
Minh says it will well I don't take my
Calot no one will ever use it
you mark my words dick the time will
come when we will all use it while we
may even talk with distant cities with
distant City Oh John your detective
dreamer
you